everybody Sean McGinnis an Alex new
house here we're gonna take a little
look at the PlayStation now beta Alex
you've actually been messing around with
this quite a bit huh yeah I've been
playing around with this seeing the
prices checking it out a little bit and
yeah yeah cuz I've heard from people
heard through the grapevine that
PlayStation now is not exactly a
terribly good value at the moment yeah
so the prices are kind of all over the
place like you get you can have some
that a reasonable that makes sense and
some that are absolutely just nonsense
going well I mean let's take a look at
those right now I want to see what kind
of spectrum we can find here right so I
must start out with something reasonable
something that I think you know is a
good price for a couple hours a couple a
couple days of a renting game let's
let's check out Killzone 3 shot all
right Killzone 3 it is yep on this
pretty good pretty good game i think i
played in i enjoyed it enough it was a
pretty good shooter on the ps3 from a
couple years back and as you can see
there are several different options for
rental period that you choose from you
can rent it for four hours 7 days 30
days in 90 days okay so like seven days
for six bucks you'll beat the campaign
will probably play you know quite a few
hours of multiplayer and that seems like
a pretty decent amount of time for like
six bucks yeah I think so I mean you
from what I saw you can like I fit in
about nine hours and if you're playing
like an hour a day or if you even want
to bump it up to 30 days unifying you
know a couple hours a week that's
totally fine that's not too bad um yeah
that I think that's reasonable for a
pretty for a good game where you get the
full campaign experience and the
multiplayer as well but I mean that is
one of the reasonable games right
Killzone is a game that kind of exists
at one end of the spectrum it's one of
Sony's first party games so there's an
incentive for them to charge as little
as possible for that because they're
trying to promote the service right it
seems like other Kames maybe aren't
always that good of a value yeah so
let's check out something like
Darksiders 2 which came out in 2012 and
isn't nearly as good of a value so as
you can see in this it starts out of 5
bucks for four hours and goes all the
way up to 30 for 90 days so if you want
to read the gate from 90 days reminder
this is not our
right owning the game this is 90 days
it's thirty dollars which is way more
than a new copy of this game costs on
amazon right now right that's kind of
ridiculous to me right I mean you're
what I think Sonny's trying to say is
like you're paying for the convenience
of playing these games ideas for it
because like obviously this isn't
available on this console right now sure
yeah and if you never had a ps3 not you
don't on one now then maybe you'll feel
like yeah maybe for for a week I'll
check out Darksiders for seven bucks but
still like you can prop like you can
find a used copy of darksiders to a
physical copy that you own forever
unlimited use for third like for the
same price of the cost for a month right
so you're paying there's a premium for
convenience built into these prices
you're not you don't have to take the
time to download them you don't have to
buy a copy a physical copy off amazon or
gamestop right you you can play it on a
device that's not native to the game
itself right so that that kind of stuff
does seem built into the price but this
is actually not the most ridiculous one
that you smell right no it's not um what
about f1 23 yeah let's check out f1 just
gonna go straight to 13 let's just go
straight to the most ridiculous so right
away you can see that the lowest price
shows up there is from seven dollars
okay so let's jump in and see the
options that you can use so seven
dollars is for four hours of gameplay
let's keep it that let's make that clear
okay the prices go all the way up to
fifty dollars for 90 days for a 90-day
rental this game and so it's to be fair
it is a hard game to find anywhere
physically turn but then again you can
also I think you can find it on amazon
for about 40 bucks yeah so Amazon like
I'm looking at it right now the ps3
version is 40 bucks the 360 version is
60 so you know it's you know amazon
prices can fluctuate for games that have
been out for a while depending on like
out what the stock is like but right
still ours for a rental because we don't
even own the game that's just like this
is a rental maybe I'm standing on
ceremony here but like I just have a
weird issue with charging that much for
a just a rental me too and it's in a way
it's hard to criticize it because it's
also like both compared to the lowest
price you can buy the game for it's
really not it's
around the same price for 90 days you're
getting on the ps4 but then again it is
fifty dollars for a rental and it goes
away after 90 days in this game is my
might be something that you want to keep
playing for quite a quite a bit of time
because it is a reason game it's it's
it's just so interesting to me because
PlayStation Plus is one of the greatest
values and video games today like
everybody I know who has PlayStation
Plus absolutely loves it like the
caliber of free games that you get every
month is incredible right for what you
spend on an annual subscription my
station now just kind of seems to be the
opposite yeah so for the same price as
it would cost you to rent f1 2013 for
for three months you can buy your
PlayStation Plus gets six games a month
for free that's amazing yeah so okay so
you're definitely paying a premium for
convenient here yeah and it's really I
feel like from these prices is really
directed that people who don't own a ps3
and yeah it seems so different so
opposite from what they do with
PlayStation Plus that I don't really
understand exactly what they're going
for here ok so we jumped into Killzone 3
and check out what exactly places and
I'll get you like the kind of equality
of the game that you that you can buy or
rent for 15 bucks for 90 days in this
case so this is a little bit of Killzone
freeze multiplayer this games from 2011
actually still looks pretty good on this
playing with a bunch of people on
dedicated ps3 so this isn't like a
PlayStation now game and already I
noticed that the latency something like
my emotions on the controller to what
appears on screen is very noticeable and
so for a first person shooter like this
this is a this is a big problem because
first person shooters or rely on twitch
movements and when it takes a half
second for your motion to appear on
screen that's a pretty big deal yeah so
also in places now at least in this game
be the controls are based on the ps3
controller so these shoulder buttons
instead of the triggers the shoulder
buttons are what you use to fire and
from what I could tell you cannot change
that
so Killzone 3 already has weed controls
and having to use the shoulder buttons
on the ps4 controller isn't necessarily
the best option the best solution for
this hopefully when PlayStation now goes
and like has a full release you'll be
able to change up the controls a little
bit more as it is I'm only able to use
the ps3 controls on a ps4 controller
yessum from this first quick look at the
place is now service in this this quick
bit of multicolored multiplayer of
matching because on three that we just
played on it seems like PlayStation now
really has some latency palms to
overcome before it is actually a
meaningful and legitimate option for
playing these games at least which based
shooters it would obviously work for a
game like wakame they are like a
turn-based strategy game or something
that doesn't require twitch movement but
48 which based multiplayer game the
response time on the controller is just
too much and so we'll have to see in the
future if they can iron these problems
out and before the full release of
PlayStation now well guys that's a I
guess that does it that's your look at
the PlayStation now beta as it stands
right now but you know like we said it
is a beta maybe these prices will get
better maybe not I don't know we'll have
to see how it goes but definitely right
now PlayStation now kind of be careful
with this one because you could you
could definitely end up spending a lot
more money than you really need to if
you just buy a game though right so
there you have it stay tuned for more
coverage
I